las fuerzas armadas serbias en nivel
máximo de alerta debido a las latentes
tensiones en el norte de kosovo con los
servocos ovares de la región desafiando
y bloqueando las vías desde el pasado 10
de diciembre denunciando
discriminaciones por parte del gobierno
kosovar al que no reconocen como
autoridad independiente fue la detención
de un ex policía ahora en libertad
sospechoso de participar en agresiones
contra policías de etnia albanesa lo que
terminó de caldear el clima
estamos en un gueto vivimos bajo cadenas
y candados creo que sería mejor que se
calmaran tanto Alvin curti como todos
los suyos
en respuesta Cristina cerró este
miércoles su mayor paso fronterizo con
el país vecino también la policía
clausuró el único aeropuerto de kosovo
tras una supuesta amenaza de bomba y
acusan a Belgrado de apoyar los bloqueos
Lamentablemente estos criminales
sancionados por Estados Unidos y Reino
Unido están siendo apoyados por el
presidente y el gobierno de Serbia con
el objetivo de desestabilizar la región
además de violar la integridad
territorial de nuestra República las
instituciones de kosovo No hablarán ni
cooperarán con los criminales sino que
los arrestarán
tanto la misión de la otan café como
Estados Unidos la Unión Europea se han
movilizado para pedir el diálogo y
evitar una escalada que lleva al
conflicto la Unión Europea y los Estados
Unidos de América Están preocupados por
la persistente situación de tensión en
el norte de kosovo hacemos un llamado a
todos a ejercer la máxima moderación y a
tomar medidas inmediatas para calmar
incondicionalmente la situación y a
abstenerse de provocaciones amenazas o
intimidaciones Serbia no reconoce la
Independencia del territorio de kosovo
que declaró su independencia unilateral
en 2008 desde entonces Belgrado ha
animado a los servocos ovarios de la
zona norte donde son mayoría a desafiar
a las autoridades de pristina